eh cambios debería hacer México para
poder cumplir esta reducción de gases de
efecto invernadero anunciada por el
canciller
qué tal Rodrigo muy buenas noches y
estoy todo tu auditorio Pues en primer
lugar lo que se necesita es darle marcha
atrás a la política energética del
presidente López Obrador iniciada en el
recién en 2012 2019 de igual manera
Tendría que haber cambios sustanciales
al programa Nacional de del sistema
eléctrico nacional dado que es uno de
los principales causantes de emisiones
efecto invernadero al igual que las
actividades del petróleos mexicanos dado
que para la programación financiera para
estos planes de trabajo del sector
energético no se tiene contemplado ni un
peso para la aplicación en energía
renovables y es la cooperación entre
países clave para la transición
energética hacia unas energías menos
contaminantes ha trascendido algo más de
los detalles del acuerdo entre México y
Estados Unidos
este acuerdo sin duda alguna es es
importante para para ambas naciones a
nivel geopolítico es sumamente
importante sin embargo hay que recordar
que este acuerdo también va a operar al
interior del país y y al interior del
país la operancia este financiera va a
estar o está socavada habría que estar
esperando o estar viendo puntualmente
los avances que se tengan este trabajo
bilateral entre el canciller mexicano
ebrard y el y el ministro Kerry y
abriendo el foco a la región de América
Latina Cuáles son los principales retos
que enfrenta esta región para hacer es
la transición ya citada ha sacado algún
tipo de acuerdo al respecto de la con 27
Bueno realmente a partir de este evento
de Gran importancia de la Copa 27 el
estado mexicano únicamente ha recogido
este acuerdo con el gobierno americano
el cual pues hay que recordar que está
en el marco de una de un conflicto
comercial de nuestro tratado de libre
comercio que tenemos actualmente
Precisamente en el sector energético y
ya en el sector América Latina
desgraciadamente no ha habido un
acercamiento de la cancillería con las
demás regiones del país o los demás
países del continente americano